foreign
[Music]
coordinator for the Witcher season three oh
Mr Cavill uh Henry Cavill I'm here to find
out who can play another Witcher so this role
is very physically demanding and Netflix put
you both forwards I need to see your skills
and talents are you from Germany I'm from
Germany I love German man
great ready Jesus Christ absolutely very hungry
for a big German Frankfurter first time I
had like a [__] melon oh what [Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay ladies so as a Witcher you need to be
able to write we can ride our horse oh a horse
yes I have a lot of experience with horse
medication so I need to see how long you can
stay on oh I'm allergic to horses I'm like
definitely yeah I am that's why you and I
don't get along do you have any like uh advice
for technique just stay tight stay tight what
might be a problem I'm out I'm out we may
never see that horse again disappear okay
she will be a witch I didn't know what a Witcher
is
I thought we were going to be an actual witch
I'm just glad I didn't know where my Winifred
Sanderson costume all right let's go all right
bye girl bye don't die [__] you going
down oh wow you guys got bigger ass than you
oh it's spread eagle Brown
[Music] this is how bad [__] ride a horse
some of y'all [__] can't even spell horse
hit it
you're ready yeah all right let's go oh yeah
put your legs around otherwise great a month
is coming
[Music] [Applause] you need to look strong
our step back [__] here you go oh my God
I'm so dizzy okay
oh here we go that's not bad it's not bad
I think about the style have you got underwear
on no underwear honey I'm rotten dirty
oh
girl you pussycat Philip help me I'll always
come prepared honey you're gonna get me he
wanted us to ride him like that [__] horse
when we were on that horse I actually saw
him seat belt himself [Music]
that horse really ridden me wrong girl middle
balls are on fire here hi hello hey ladies
well done on a horse she's prolapsed yeah
so next challenge learn to fight oh weapons
yeah I think I give them just straight to
you oh yeah oh wow
not bad you hold it quite well yeah Butch
[Laughter] yeah so I don't want to see a lot
of swinging sword which is just you know going
around swinging yeah so strong end poses for
example that you come in and Chase and I have
a good stand and a good pose so words are
heavy I don't know if I can lift those the
only weapon I've ever used in my life is myself
so I'm gonna pretend somebody's come from
behind me I'm just walking you know walking
yeah
oh yeah huh that was I I can't lie that was
good I came in front that was good I want
to see the difference obviously you're two
different body types so why could you expand
on that yeah what do you mean each of you
has a different body language okay I leave
my ass she leads with her throat you know
I come from the top but important is when
I come that you're not already there so you
need to delay [Laughter] listen when you're
ready to come I'll be here to receive you
okay are you lay in your block ready three
two one stop here we go yeah great okay so
important is now a nice shot through that
we see that okay the same how are you going
to receive yeah oh Facebook so we have a dummy
for practicing so she's in the room hey
all right so here's our friend Gemma Collins
is really she's not doing well honey she is
not doing well so now the sword skills you
just learned use all your energy but stop
right in front of his face or his body you
start first oh God I just switch with you
I don't know what I want to call them what
should we call it bugger bitcher [__]
at the [__] yeah all right oh I think
I think I think them tracks are sewn in Honey
she's a sew-in okay so nice cool nice cool
strong
oh
now the web oh it's quite horny you like Xena
the [__] princess yeah the training dummy
was cute actually I have another bit in weeks
I just [__] shag a traffic light if it
gave me the green light at the minute all
right let me Adam let me Adam look at all
this silicone girl he's like you babe I don't
want to hurt you girl but here we go I wish
I had that body concentrate my name
don't hit oh yeah we got that part new character
oh oh that's a trick and now turn because
the long hair looks great when you turn oh
yeah here we go great Gandalf the same finish
again money from here into here you stay here
strong strong
he was so innocent I think he taught us a
lot but we also taught him a lot Wolfgang
Wolfgang what's his name um [Music]
here we go the final all about fight choreography
no pressure is good here you go I leave it
to you you better bet on black Wolfie [Music]
you're going down [__] on guard [Music]
[Music]
that's what you get for Killingly
yeah oh
that's the one I went through the bag of chips
I love that song that's really good we really
did that I've never used the weapon and uh
she's American she's a gun's old
you're not wrong [Music] [Applause] [Music]
well done guys thank you so both of you you
did very well and I have to say I'm super
proud of you guys and I have to give it to
you both the thing is it's so difficult what
you guys had to do we got jewelry of course
okay The Witcher medal yeah it's not gonna
fit on my head oh you know what I'm gonna
wear it as well so bad actually yeah it's
gorgeous what did you think is the result
of my name the [__] time I am sick of
ties I don't even like bow ties anymore I
tied I was robbed and then I tied again ain't
that a [__] does this mean um Netflix
is gonna call us sure